[Music] In
this world it's kill or be killed There's no such thing as
a raccoon There are people who struggle in this world saying that once they fall, it
's
all over
I'll show you how to make it bloom once It's a smile
flower  It
's hard, not even one person has a lot of painful appointments
Attachment is municipal
ah ah ah ah In
the case of His Majesty Joe
's heart
It's sama Today 0
people Please help me If that's what you're talking about, hurry up Variable flame
park
We must always be right If we have a right heart The world will respond
It's not me, I'll show you how cool it is Eri Nakama, the
detective fairy
What's going on with me?
Is it a group
of people who are posh as Her Majesty's koto?